مع التطبيق الذي يصاحبنا على الدوام وقصصه
التي لا تنتهي مع قائده الجديد تويتر
سيكون تطبيق كل شيء قالها الملك الجديد
للموقع ايلون ماسك بعد ان استحوذ عليه
يبدو انه بدا يطبقها بالعمل على اتاحه
اولى الخدمات عليه وهي خدمه الدرس تويتر
التي اعلنت انها سددت 300 مليون دولار من
فوائد الديون تمثل اول اقساط الاستحواذ
البالغ اثني عشر.5 مليار دولار وبمشاركه
سبعه بنوك الا ان الديون لا تزال تمثل
عبئا ثقيلا صحيفه نشرت الخبر وقالت ان
اتاحه ميزه الدفع عبر تويتر تعد جزءا مهما
من خطه مصر ايجاد مصادر دخل بديله
للاعلانات التي شهدت تدهورا في نشاطها
في السابق قال انه يسعى الى جعل تويتر
قادرا على تقديم الخدمات التقنيه الماليه
بما تشمله من معاملات وحسابات توفير
وبطاقات خصم ذلك في اطار خطه كبرى لتحويل
تويتر الى تطبيق الشامل المستخدمين على
غرار تطبيق ويتشات الصيني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
على كل من عمان ينضم الينا الخبير في امن
المعلومات رائد سمور سيد رائد اهلا بك من
جديد يسعد صباحك معنا في الصباح العربيه
[موسيقى]
على تقديم خدمات التقنيه الماليه من دفع
وعمله ماليه
طبعا سوف ينجح انا اعتقد انه الان يعني
عاد القطار الى السكه الحقيقيه وهذا الخبر
اللي حضراتكم اليوم يعني تحدثت عنه هو
يعني في له مقدمات من تسع ايام من تسعه
ايام كانت هناك ايضا خبر من تويتر انه لن
يجدد الاتفاقيات مع التطبيقات الدفع التي
تستخدم تقنيات اللي هي الابليكيشن
بروجرامنج انترفيس بمعنى انه اكثر من
تطبيقين يتم رمز يمكن اكثر من تطبيقين او
برمجيتين من الحديث مع بعض دون ملاحظه
المستخدم بمعنى انه كل تطبيقات الدفع الان
اللي موجوده على تويتر لن يتم التجديد
التعاقد معها وسوف يتم الاتجاه نحو الدفع
المباشر من منصه تويتر
بشكل مباشر انا اعتقد انه بس بس اوضح هذه
النقطه انا اعتقد انه الان انه الماس كنا
عم يسير في منصه تويتر نحو شواطئ برا
الامان وان ال ال ال الامر يسير وفق خطه
وهذا ما يقنعنا الان من خلال هذه التوجهات
الاقتصاديه الهامه جدا الحقيقه ولكن ايضا
معلومه بسيطه هي هي ليس لتعويض خسائر همم
الاعلانات وانما سوف تعود الاعلانات مره
اخرى وسوف يتم استخدام اليه الدفع من خلال
هذه الغايه وانا اعتقد انه اذا تحول
التطبيق الى همم ما يشبه
التويتر يعني في هناك منتج خاصه ويخرج همم
مزيد من هذه التطبيقات سوف نشاهد تطبيق
بنكهه جديده وبيروح جديده
يعني اليوم المعلنون لحظه استحواذ على
تويتر انسحب كثير منهم اليوم مع خاصيه دفع
الكتروني هل سينسحب المستخدمون هذه المره
على غرار المعلنين الذين انصحبوا لحظه
استحواذ ماسك وهل تؤتمن هذه الاموال عندما
نتحدث عن اكبر خاسر في التاريخ البشري
اليوم الى الماسك
لا هي عمليه الدفع
عمليه الدفع تحتاج الى ترخيص وتحتاج الى
شروط مهمه من قبل الحكم الفيدراليه
واللجنه التجاره الفيدراليه الامريكيه لا
يمكن ان يسمحوا بعمليه الدفع هيك بطريقه
يعني
جذافا لابد ان يمر هذه الطريقه من خلال
فحص ومن خلال شروط خاصه معينه وبالتالي
تطمئن من يقوم بعمليات الدفع ومعلومات من
يكون بعمليات الدفع هذه كمان ايضا خصوصيه
ونظام الخصوصيه فيها جدا مهم وانا اعتقد
انه ما دام في هناك طريقه للدفع بشكل
مباشر انا اعتذر حتى الاعلام اذا ما عادت
المنصه الى طريقتها الصحيحه
بعمل اداري اقتصادي صحيح انا اعتقد حتى
الاعلام سوف يعود الى المنصه مره اخرى
وسوف يعني تذهب هذه المنصه الى يعني خطوات
متقدمه الى الامام وليس الى كما كانت انا
اعتقد وصلنا الى حد الاستقرار همم
التقني الاداري في مناصره تويتر وبالتالي
سوف تذهب هذه المنصه الى ابعد من ذلك
بكثير شكرا جزيلا من عمان الخبير في امن
المعلومات رائد سموه